ERICA FOX: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us live
and on the livestream.
And it's my great pleasure
to have this conversation
today with Alison.
And for those of
you who have not
yet read her book
"On the Edge," I
thought we might start by
having her take us back
to May 24, 2010 and
tell us a little bit
about that day and that moment.
ALISON LEVINE: May
24, 2010 was the day
that I completed what's known as
the Adventure Grand Slam, which
is climbing the seven
summits, the highest
peak on each continent,
and then skiing to both
the North and the South Pole.
May 24, 2010 is when I summited
Mount Everest to complete
the Adventure Grand Slam.
And it was my second
attempt at the mountain.
I made my first attempt in 2002.
I was the team captain of the
First American Women's Everest
Expedition.
And we got this
close to the summit
and had to turn
around in bad weather.
We turned around just a few
hundred feet in a storm.
So that was, of
course, disappointing.
Because we were the First
American Women's Everest
Expedition, we had all
this media coverage.
And then we didn't make it.
And it took me eight years
before I got up enough guts
to go back to the
mountain and try it again.
But I went back in 2010.
Did make it to the summit.
And that was the
Adventure Grand Slam.
ERICA FOX: It's hard
to even fathom what
goes into that accomplishment.
So could you tell
us a little bit
about the path
that got you there?
And particularly from
reading your book,
it seems quite an unusual
path starting in there's
some investment banking time.
There's some other adventures.
And I thought that this
group would be particularly
interested in that, because
many individuals here at Google
have quite unusual paths.
And if they trace back how
they got to where they are now,
they might not have ever
anticipated where they are.
So I'd love for
you to just walk us
through a little bit of that.
ALISON LEVINE: Sure.
Well, when I was younger,
for whatever reason,
I was just very intrigued by
the stories of the early Arctic
and Antarctic explorers
and the early mountaineers.
So I'd read these books.
I'd watched documentary films.
And long story short, but I was
born with a hole in my heart
that got bigger as I got older.
So I've had three
heart surgeries.
But after my second one,
when I was 30 years old,
I had my second heart surgery.
And I was in pretty
good health after that.
And about 18 months
after that procedure,
this light bulb
went on in my head.
And I thought, all
right, if I want
to know what it's like
to be Reinhold Messner
and drag a 150-pound sled across
600 miles of Antarctic ice,
then I should get out
there and do it instead
of just reading about it.
If I want to know what it's like
to be these early mountaineers
and these explorers that are
going to these remote mountain
regions, then I should go
to remote mountain regions
instead of just watching
documentary films about it.
And so that kind of sparked
this interest in me.
And I started having
these adventures.
And of course, I
started on lower peaks
that didn't have a lot of
technical requirements.
You could just walk
up Kilimanjaro, right?
If you had determination,
you could do this mountain
because it doesn't require
any technical abilities,
it just requires some stamina--
ERICA FOX: Grit.
ALISON LEVINE: --and grit.
Exactly Right?
So I am from Arizona, so I
didn't have any warm clothes.
And I borrowed warm
clothes from friends.
I borrowed a backpack, a
tent, everything I needed.
Used frequent flyer miles
to go to the base of Mount
Kilimanjaro in Tanzania--
I just went by myself--
hired a guide at the base of the
mountain for a couple hundred
bucks, and ended up
climbing Kilimanjaro.
And that was the first
mountain that I climbed.
And that was where I found
that voice in my head
that told me that I
could keep going when
I felt like I wanted to quit.
And it was that voice that
really gave me the confidence
to know that no matter what
mountain I was tackling,
from that point on,
I had that voice
that told me that
I could keep going.
So it is really about grit.
So that's just kind of how I
started going to the mountains
and having these adventures.
But I never really planned
on completing the seven
summits, you know, the highest
peak on each continent,
or completing the
Adventure Grand
Slam by skiing to the
North and South Pole
in addition to seven summits,
but it just kind of happened
over time.
And I would go on
these adventures
and I would meet people
climbing that would invite me
on other adventures.
And by the time I went
back to Everest in 2010,
I had climbed the highest
peak on six continents, skied
to both the North
and the South Pole,
and I knew it was
just that one mountain
that I needed to do to complete
the Adventure Grand Slam.
But in between
doing all of that,
I did have a normal, you
know, semi-normal career.
I worked in pharmaceutical
and medical device industry.
I worked in investment
banking for a couple of years
right after graduate school.
I got an MBA.
And when I went to
get my MBA, I thought
it was because I was going to
start this adventure travel
company.
And then somehow I got roped
into this investment banking
job, because I wanted to learn
about finance and accounting
and things I had
no background in.
And I thought if I wanted
to do that, I should
try to go to Wall Street,
because that's where I could
get my feet wet in those areas.
And so one thing led to another.
But I just kept
feeling this pull back
to the adventure world.
So the investment banking
thing didn't last very long.
ERICA FOX: So as the mom of
two middle-schoolers right now,
I just can't help but ask,
what were you like as a child?
And did you have this
draw to adventure,
this draw to putting yourself
out there and not quitting?
Did you see signs of
that at a young age?
ALISON LEVINE: It didn't.
So I think I liked frustrating
my parents as a child probably.
I mean, who doesn't?
But I didn't really think
that I could do anything
like this until I turned 30 and
I had that second heart surgery
and I was in much better health.
And at that point, I
just thought, well,
what's holding me back?
I don't have any
health challenges
that are preventing
me from doing this.
I do have what's called
Raynaud's disease, which
is a disease where
the nerves clamp down
on the blood vessels in
your fingers and toes,
cutting off your circulation.
So doctors have always told
me to avoid cold environments.
And of course, I
didn't listen to that.
But I just used
those hand warmers.
I figure there's always a way
around these roadblocks, right?
So for me, they said
no cold environments,
because your hands
and toes will freeze.
And I was like, can't I
just use those hand warmers?
Sometimes there's a
really simple solution
to something that feels like
it's an overwhelming problem.
And so I don't think I did
anything too crazy or too
adventurous as a kid.
But I probably did
drive my parents crazy.
ERICA FOX: So you
talked a little bit
about what fuels you
in terms of don't
go read about the mountains,
go and put yourself there.
Once you got back
from those trips,
what then did you tap
into that compelled
you to get involved in
more leadership work
to take this path forward?
ALISON LEVINE: I realized
that there was a lot of blood,
sweat, and tears that goes into
these expeditions, everything
from pre-expedition training
and planning and getting
the logistics organized and then
the time that you're actually
on the mountain or in
Antarctica or the Arctic Circle
or wherever you are
doing these adventures.
And sometimes you don't
always achieve the goal
that you set out to achieve.
And I figured out that
if you focus solely
on getting to the
top of a mountain,
you are missing
so much of what is
important about these
types of adventures.
Because standing on top of a
mountain doesn't change you.
It doesn't change the world.
It doesn't change anything.
What's important are the lessons
that you learn along the way
when you're fighting like hell
to get up there and then what
you're going to do
with that information
to be better going forward.
And I figured out
by really studying
the art and science
of leadership
and by sharing my experiences
with others, whether it's
something like this
that we're doing today
or lecturing at a corporate
event or my time spent
on the part-time
faculty at West Point,
sharing those leadership lessons
is what changes the world
and is what helps people
become better in whatever area
they're trying to
become better in.
So for me, focusing on
the leadership stuff
was a way that I could take my
experiences from the mountain
and share them in a way that
would actually help people.
ERICA FOX: And in what ways
has being a woman contributed
to the way you show up as
a leader, your professional
and athletic successes?
ALISON LEVINE: So
being a woman, and I
know this is going to sound
like something I shouldn't say,
but being a woman in certain
situations is a disadvantage.
And I know before everyone's
like, wait a minute!
So in the business
world, I do feel
like women can compete
with men on every level,
whether it's intellectual
capability or creativity
or determination or
whatever it takes
to be really good at your job.
But when it comes to
these expeditions,
while we like to think
that everybody's equal,
the law of physics
basically dictates
that we're not all equal.
And it's not just
about being a woman,
necessarily, it's about being
someone who's my size, right?
So it's not my gender,
it's my physical size.
So what I discovered when
I went on this South Pole
expedition-- and this is
a chapter in the book.
It's chapter six.
And it seems to be everyone's
favorite chapter, I think,
because it's a
very honest chapter
about a difficult situation
where I really struggled.
But I showed up for the
South Pole expedition.
And I always train as hard as
I can before an expedition,
because that's just who I am.
I'm going to show up.
I'm going to be ready.
I'm going to be prepared.
There's no way I'm not going
to be the most prepared person
on the trip, because I feel
like I owe it to my teammates
to be that person.
So I trained as hard as I could,
showed up for this expedition.
And what I discovered was
that even though I trained
really hard, that
my size was what
was preventing me
from performing
as well as my teammates.
So like I said, the law
of physics basically
dictates that somebody
who's my size--
5'4, about 112 pounds--
is not going to be able to pull
a 150-pound sled as quickly
or as efficiently as somebody
who is 6'3, 220, 230 pounds.
So I wasn't able to keep
up with my teammates.
And it was very
evident that I was
the slowest person on the team,
because I was behind everybody.
And it really caused me
a lot of frustration,
because my teammates
were constantly
having to wait for me.
And you might think
that that's no big deal.
But in Antarctica, when you have
to stop and wait for somebody,
you're going to get cold, right?
So here I am.
My teammates are potentially
becoming hypothermic waiting
for me, because I am
the slowest, weakest
person on the team.
No matter how hard I tried, I
was still the slowest, weakest
person on the team.
And I thought about
how I perceived
slower, weaker people, right?
Whether it was in a
business environment
or on an expedition, I used
to think about slower people
and think, oh, man, I wish that
person wasn't part of my team.
That person is weaker.
That person is holding us back.
That person is slowing us down.
We would be so much better,
so much more productive
if we didn't have that person.
So maybe that person will
transfer to another division
or quit this job or
quit this expedition
or choose to be a
part of another team.
Please just get
them off of my team.
Well, all of a sudden,
I'm that person.
I'm the slowest, weakest person.
And that really caused me to
double down on my frustration.
Because not only was I
struggling physically,
but now I was struggling
psychologically
and emotionally, just knowing
for sure that nobody wanted me
on the team.
And the way our
team leader handled
this situation changed
my approach to leadership
completely.
So instead of
saying to me, you're
slower, you're weaker
you're holding us back,
what's the problem, I
overheard our team leader
Eric talking in his tent
to my teammate George.
And I heard Eric
say, poor Alison.
She's really struggling
with the weight of her sled.
And George said, I know.
She's so much smaller
than everybody.
We should really
try to help her out.
And Eric said, yeah,
we're going to do that.
We're going to help her out.
And the next day, they
got out of their tent.
And Eric said, hey!
Before we start
off today, I just
want to weigh everybody's
sled and make sure they're
about the same weight, right?
Because you have this
big 150-pound sled.
And George said,
yeah, let's do that.
Let's make sure
they're all about even.
So they get out of their
tent and they pick up
the end of George's sled.
And they're like, oh, OK,
yeah, this one feels good.
Let's weigh Eric's sled.
They pick up the
end of Eric's sled.
Yeah, this one feels good.
Let's weigh Merete's sled.
They each pick up the end
of this big 150-pound sled.
OK, yeah, this one feels good.
All right, let's
weigh Alison's sled.
And they each get on
the end of my sled.
They pick it up.
They get it six
inches off the ground.
And they both drop it.
And they're like, oh, my god!
And This is the heaviest sled!
This is so crazy!
Why are you carrying
so much more
weight than everybody else?
And I knew what they were
doing, because I overheard them.
And I thought, um, well.
Eric's like, well,
this is crazy.
We got to make this more even.
And they pulled weight
out of my sled, right?
They took a couple
fuel canisters out,
they lightened up my sled
so that I could keep up
with everybody else.
And now their sleds
are heavier than mine.
So I start thinking, wow,
what an amazing leader.
He let me keep my pride intact.
He made me feel like I was a
valuable member of the team.
And instead of saying,
hey, you're slow,
we're going to take
weight out of your sled
and make our sleds heavier,
they sent me a message
that they wanted me to succeed
and they wanted to support me.
So I immediately
start thinking, what
am I going to do to pay
these people back, right?
Because they've
helped me sort of
compensate for this weakness.
They've helped me, in a sense,
overcome it at the time.
And so what I noticed was
these taller guys, the men who
were taller, they were
really wrenching their backs
trying to shovel snow every day.
Because at the end of
skiing for 15 hours,
at the end of the day,
you pitch this tent
and you have to build a snow
barricade around your tent
to protect it from the elements.
So you're already
completely exhausted, right?
And then you have to
build your snow barricade.
And I noticed these taller
guys wrenching their backs
trying to shovel snow
to build the barricade
around their tent.
So that next night after they
took weight out of my sled,
I said, hey, you guys,
can I shovel the snow
around your tent?
Because I'm shorter,
so I can shovel snow
without screwing up my back.
So I said, hey, can I shovel
the snow around your tent?
And Eric said, you
want to do what?
And I said, I want
to shovel the snow
to make the barricade
around your tent.
And he goes, why do
you want to do that?
And I said, because I
love to shovel snow.
And Eric said, come on,
you love to shovel snow.
And I said, yes, I
grew up in Phoenix
and I never got to do that.
So it's a treat for me to
be able to shovel snow.
So every day at
the end of the day,
I grabbed that snow shovel
and I shoveled the snow
around the tent to make
the snow barricade.
And at the end of
the expedition,
we made it to the South Pole.
It was almost two months.
And Eric said, I'm
just curious, I just
want to ask everyone
what's your most
memorable part of the trip.
And so everybody
was sharing that.
And I said, what's your
most memorable part
of the trip, Eric?
And he said, uh, I think
how much crazy Alison likes
to shovel snow.
And I said, are you kidding me?
I hate to shovel snow.
I said, I was only doing
that, because I overheard
you guys talking in your tent
about taking the weight out
of my sled.
And he said, oh, you heard that?
And I was like,
yeah, plus you're
the crappiest actors with, like,
oh, my back, this is so heavy.
And for me, it was
this great lesson
about accepting our weaknesses
and realizing that you're not
going to overcome every
weakness that you have,
but you can be creative
and compensate for it.
So it goes back to that
question about being a woman.
And we do want to be equal.
And we do want to
achieve as much.
And we do like to think that
the playing ground is even.
But it's not always.
And for me, I was never going
to overcome the fact that I was
so much shorter and smaller
and physically weaker than
my 6'3, 230-pound teammates.
So it was this light
bulb moment for me
where I realized that it's our
responsibilities as leaders
to help people
compensate for weakness
rather than just hammering
people to overcome
their weaknesses all the time.
Because there are
some weaknesses
that you will never overcome.
Whether you're a woman
or a man or whatever
the certain characteristics
that you have,
there are going to be weaknesses
that you should just accept.
But it doesn't mean that
you're a weaker performer,
it just means you have to
be creative and compensate.
So that's just kind of a
long-winded answer for,
how do you feel about being
a woman in these situations?
Are there challenges?
Is it an advantage
or a disadvantage?
I just say, be creative,
play to your strengths,
and realize that your strengths
might not be the same strengths
that other people have, but
everybody has that sweet spot.
And if you can be creative
and help someone else find
their sweet spot,
like Eric did for me,
you'll often get a higher
level of performance
out of that person
than you would
get from them had they been an
on par performer with everybody
else to begin with.
ERICA FOX: That makes
me think of situations
that you talk about a lot
in the book about everyone
on the team playing
a different role
and needing to
show up as a leader
or as a follower at different
parts of the expedition.
And I'm just curious, when
you think about leadership
as an attitude or a way
of being with a team as
opposed to a role, can you talk
a little bit more about that?
ALISON LEVINE: I think
everybody on a team
is in a leadership position.
So leadership is not
about title or tenure
or how many people report to
you or how big of a budget
you oversee.
Leadership's about realizing
that every member of a team
has a responsibility to help
the team move toward a goal.
And everybody also
has a responsibility
to be looking out
for one another.
If you leave leadership to one
person with a certain title
or a certain amount of tenure
and that person isn't around,
what's going to happen if
anything goes wrong, right?
So on our South Pole
expedition, the one
I was just talking about,
Eric was brilliant,
because he had
everybody sort of trade
off in different
leadership roles every day.
So every day, somebody
else was out front
breaking trail and
navigating the route,
figuring out how to do that.
Because if you rely on one
person for route finding or one
person for assessing
avalanche danger or one person
for cooking the meals,
I mean, whatever it is,
if that person isn't
around, for whatever reason,
what are you going to do, right?
So everybody has to be
able to sort of step
into a different type of role
when called upon to do so.
And that's why it's so
important for everybody
to empower themselves to
think and act like a leader.
From the second you
walk in the door
of a building where
you work, right,
or the second you
start on an expedition,
everybody has to
realize that they
are in a leadership position.
And the other thing
is that as a leader,
it's very important to
remember that you can never
expect the people
on your team to be
willing to endure anything that
you are not willing to endure.
So you've got to be willing to
get out there in the trenches,
on the front lines, just
like the rest of the people
on your team.
ERICA FOX: So I'm
stuck between wanting
to ask you more
leadership questions
and wanting to go into, like,
ooh, tell us about something
that was really hard.
So I'll go there first.
But can you indulge
us in a story
of just one of the
situations where
you, as a leader
of the team, knew
that you had to kind
of endure something
difficult with your
team and just give us
a little taste of that--
ALISON LEVINE: Sure.
ERICA FOX: --for those
of us who haven't been
on Everest or the South Pole.
ALISON LEVINE: Yeah, I would go
back to the 2002 First American
Women's Everest Expedition
that I referenced
a little bit earlier, where
we got to within just a couple
hundred feet from
the summit and we had
to turn around in bad weather.
And what made that so
heart-wrenching is, A,
we were the First American
Women's Everest Expedition,
so we just wanted to make it.
But, B, because we had
so much media coverage,
I felt like we were
under a microscope
and that we were very
closely scrutinized.
And before we left
for the expedition,
we were on the
morning show circuit
and all the evening news
anchors were interviewing us,
450 media outlets were
following our climb,
CNN's doing live updates
from the mountain,
and then we miss it
by that much, right?
So then you come back.
And you have to go back
to all the media outlets
again, because they're like,
come back after the trip!
So you go back to
"The Today Show."
And you walk in.
And Ann Curry's
like, welcome back!
Oh.
So you deal with
that kind of thing,
where you have to
explain what happened.
And people don't realize that
it takes several hours to go
a couple hundred
feet when you're
climbing up in the Death Zone.
You could be taking five
breaths for every step
just to catch your breath again.
So we turned around a couple
hundred feet from the top.
And people were like,
why couldn't you
just run and touch the
tippy top and run back down?
Like, I don't understand!
And it's because you're taking
five breaths for every step,
so it takes a
while to get there.
And we didn't feel like we
had enough of a decent weather
window.
But to come back and have to
just talk about this failure.
And it was such
a public failure.
And you go from being this
celebrated team before you go.
And then you come
back and you're just
the butt of Jay Leno's
opening monologue joke.
And how does that feel?
And yes, that really happened.
And so it's hard when you have
a big public failure like that,
where you just you want to
achieve it for yourself,
for the team, for your sponsor.
The Ford Motor Company
sponsored our trip.
And we wanted to
make them proud.
And we felt like
America was watching.
And then we didn't do it.
ERICA FOX: And
it's so interesting
that it's literally like
stepping on that summit,
it's off or on, right?
It's black or white.
People say you made it
or you didn't make it.
ALISON LEVINE: Right.
ERICA FOX: And discounting
all the work, all the time
you spent on the mountain,
all of the accomplishments
to get as high up
on that mountain
as you could is
kind of discounted,
it seems like, right?
ALISON LEVINE: Exactly.
So cut to eight years later,
when I went back and I did
make it to the summit.
And I stood up there and
I was like, this is it?
Because people were
like, how did it
feel to go back to the
mountain eight years later,
fight your way
through the storm,
and stand on the highest
mountain in the world?
And I was like, uh,
wasn't that big of a deal.
Because that's when I
realized standing up
there doesn't change anything.
It is the journey and what
you learn along the way
and what you're going to
do with that information
to be better going forward.
Anyone that knows a little
something about the history
of Mount Everest knows the names
Sir Edmund Hillary and Tenzing
Norgay, right?
First guys to ever
summit Mount Everest.
There were dozens
of climbers who
tried and failed before those
two made it to the summit.
But those two had the
benefit of the 411, right?
The information from all
of those previous climbers.
And maybe if those other guys
hadn't tried and failed first,
Sir Edmund Hillary
and Tenzing Norgay
would never have made
it to the summit.
You just don't know.
I mean, my point is
when you're going
to try really hard
things, when you're
going to push yourself
outside of your comfort zone,
you're going to have to give
yourselves and your teams
the freedom to fail, right?
Just come back from it
better the next time around.
ERICA FOX: You also have stories
in the book about backtracking.
And I tend to think of
that on these trips,
go up, acclimate, come back.
And how do you get the team
to go along with you when
seemingly you're taking them
in the reverse direction
of progress?
And I'm interested
on the mountain,
but I'm also interested
sort of outside
of the mountain in
a corporate setting
or in a professional setting
when backtracking is actually
the right thing to do.
But it's hard.
ALISON LEVINE: Right.
It is so hard.
So let me paint a little
picture for you of what it's
like to climb Mount Everest.
Because the process of the climb
is not at all straightforward.
You don't just get to base
camp and climb to Camp 1
and climb to Camp 2 and climb
to Camp 3 and get to Camp 4
and get to the summit.
It's going to take
you 10 days of hiking
just to get yourself
to base camp.
Once you get to
base camp, you have
to spend a few days
and nights there
to get used to the altitude,
because it's over 17,000 feet.
So then once you've been
there for a few days,
then you climb up
to the next camp.
Climb up to Camp 1.
Spend the night at Camp 1.
And the next day, you come
back to base camp again.
Spend a few nights
at base camp again.
Climb to Camp 1 again.
Spend the night.
Then you climb to Camp 2 and you
spend the night up at Camp 2.
After you spend the night
up at Camp 2, the next day,
you come back down
to base camp again.
Spend a few nights
at base camp again.
Climb to Camp 1 again.
Next day, climb to Camp 2 again.
Next day, you're going to
climb all the way up to Camp 3.
It's almost 24,000 feet.
And after you spend the night
up at 24,000 feet, the next day,
you pack up and you come all
the way back down to base camp
again.
And the reason you have
to keep coming back down
is because you have to let your
body get used to the altitude
very slowly.
It's this process
called acclimatization.
And if someone were to
magically drop you off
on the summit of Mount Everest,
if you could be dropped up
there by a plane or a helicopter
or something like that,
you'd be dead in a matter of
minutes just from the altitude.
So you have to move
up really slowly just
so your head doesn't pop off
when you get to the very top.
And I mean, it doesn't
really just pop off.
But the catch is
that any time you're
above about 18,000 feet,
which is going to be
any camp above that base camp--
base camp's about 17,500.
Any time you're
above that elevation,
your body is starting
to deteriorate
and your muscles
are getting weaker.
So it's this crazy
catch-22 of you
want to spend time up high
to get used to the altitude,
but you have to keep
coming back down
low just so you can eat,
sleep, hydrate, and regain
some strength.
So not only is it
a very physically
challenging to be going up, back
down, up higher, and back down
again, but psychologically,
super frustrating as well.
Because you know you want
to be going this way, right?
But you're spending a
heck of a lot of time
climbing in this direction.
But what you have to realize
is that even though you
are going completely backwards
where you're like, oh, my god,
this is not the direction
I want to go, you are still
making progress, because you're
helping your body acclimatize.
And for whatever
reason, we always
tend to think that
progress has to happen
in one particular direction,
but that's not the case.
Sometimes you are going to
have to go backwards for a bit
in order to eventually get
to where you want to be.
So don't ever look at that
backtracking as losing ground.
Look at it as an opportunity to
regroup, regain some strength,
so you're better out of the
gates the next time around.
And I tell my team all
the time, backing up
is not the same as backing down.
OK, that's one of my
best lines, by the way.
So if you're going to
write down anything,
I would go with that one.
Backing up is not the
same as backing down.
ERICA FOX: So speaking of
the camps and the base camp
and Camp 1 and Camp 2, you
write about emotional obligation
in your book.
And I think there was a section
about going tent to tent
and getting to know people and--
ALISON LEVINE: Yes.
ERICA FOX: --creating
some sense--
or this is how I interpret
it-- creating some sense
among the other
climbers that there
was a connection
between the two of you.
And that they would feel
some emotional connection.
In the event that
you needed help,
they may go out of
their way to help you.
And it was fascinating.
And I was thinking about
the translation of that
in the corporate setting.
And just wondered if you
could talk about that a bit.
ALISON LEVINE: So
first thing I do
when I get to base camp on any
mountain, very first thing,
I walk around, I talk to
every other team that's there.
And people think it's
because I'm so social.
But I'm actually not social.
I'm an extreme,
extreme introvert.
I love my time alone in my tent.
But I walk around and I talk to
every other team at base camp
because if, god forbid,
something should happen
to someone on one of my teams, I
would need the people around us
to feel obligated
to help us, right?
And there's a chapter in the
book that talks about rescues
on Mount Everest and why some
people are rescued from high
up on the mountain and others,
unfortunately, are not rescued.
And it's tragic
that that happens.
It should never happen.
But the reality is
that it does happen.
And there are a lot of factors
that go into whether or not
somebody can even be
brought down from high up
on that mountain.
But one thing that always
works in people's favor
is if they happen to know
the people walking past them
at the time.
Because people who know you
are, of course, much more
likely to go out of
their way for you,
potentially take on a large
amount of personal risk for you
if you have that
relationship in place.
And I think the mistake
that's often made
is people think that because
their team's working really
well together that that's
all they need to worry about.
But you have to
be very strategic.
Think about who
outside of your team
you might need to call on
for help at some point.
And you want to have those
relationships in place
before you need the help.
So put the time and effort
into networking outside
of your immediate
team here, right,
at Google, because
you just never know
when it's going to pay off.
ERICA FOX: Yeah,
it's a great point.
And we talk a lot in our
programs and communities
here about the importance
of building relationships
within teams, within
functions, but then
people who don't even
work in your department,
both for in the event
that you need help,
but also just bringing in
different perspective on that.
ALISON LEVINE:
That's [INAUDIBLE].
ERICA FOX: So when you said
you're an extreme introvert
and you like to be
in your tent, that
made me think, what
do you do to stay sane
when you're on these trips
that seem interminable?
And if there's weather and
if you're going up and down,
one, what do you
do to stay sane?
And what do you do for fun?
ALISON LEVINE: So you
have a lot of tent time
on these expeditions, whether
it's a bad weather day or just
an acclimatization day,
right, where you've gone up,
you come back down, you got
to rest at a lower elevation,
and you can't bring
a lot of stuff
with you for entertainment,
because you're carrying
everything in your backpack.
So you can't bring a bunch of--
I mean, you can bring an iPod
or something to listen to music,
but you can't bring a
ton of books or games
or anything like that.
So I actually, when
I'm in my tent, what
I do to pass the time
and for fun is I make up
rap songs about my dog.
And no, I'm not going
to perform one of them
for you, because I don't
do them for anybody.
But that is my thing.
I'm obsessed with my dog.
I love him so much.
I have a big--
ERICA FOX: What kind of dog?
ALISON LEVINE: --100-pound
black lab named Trooper.
I dedicated my book to him.
And my husband too.
But Trooper's first.
It's like, to the most amazing,
charismatic, intelligent,
handsome,
blah-blah-blah-blah, Trooper.
And to Pat.
But I make up rap
songs about my dog,
because I'm obsessed with him.
And I love him so much.
I'm sure I have plenty of
dog lovers in the room.
But dogs are-- they're amazing.
And I think it also--
because I think dogs can bring
a sense of calm and tranquility,
it helps me to think about him.
But I make up rap
songs about him.
And I just sing them
to him when I get home,
not to anybody else.
ERICA FOX: Awesome.
One other thing
that you mentioned
is the concept of VUCA,
volatile, uncertain--
ALISON LEVINE: Complex.
ERICA FOX: --complex
and ambiguous.
And that more and more, the
environments that we're in
are these VUCA environments,
particularly for the industry
that we work in.
And many of the products
that we're launching
and the markets that we're
in have never existed before.
So I'm curious how you think
about preparation and planning
and anticipating events
and this VUCA environment.
Because some might argue that
in a uncertain and volatile
environment, you
need to actually
be very creative and
innovative about how you're
going to respond, not always
thinking you have the plan,
because the plan might not work.
ALISON LEVINE: Exactly.
ERICA FOX: How do
you reconcile this?
ALISON LEVINE: So
obviously, when
you're getting ready for
a big expedition or just
in the business world,
planning's super important.
You have to plan.
It helps keep you organized.
It helps keep you on track.
But what you have to
realize is that when
you are in environments
that are constantly shifting
and changing, and when you
have these elements that
are completely outside
of your control,
your plan might be outdated
as soon as it's finished.
Or whether you came
out with it last year,
last month, last week,
even that morning,
your plan is already
outdated, right?
As soon as it's finished,
your plan is outdated.
So what you have to do in
these types of environments is,
while it's good
to plan, you have
to be much more focused
on executing based
on what is going on at the time,
rather than being hell-bent
on sticking to your plan.
Well, this is the plan.
This is what we put together.
This is what we agreed upon.
We got to follow it.
Forget that.
You have to be much more
focused on executing
based on the situation,
not based on the plan.
ERICA FOX: And is
there a hierarchy
or a prioritization of needs,
I guess, in that moment, right?
I'm thinking,
obviously, preserving
life is probably the first one.
ALISON LEVINE: Good point.
ERICA FOX: But are
there other parameters
that you keep in mind?
If you're going to
have to shift and be
present in the situation,
what are the considerations
that you--
ALISON LEVINE: So I'm glad
you mentioned preserving life,
because that is the number one
goal of any expedition, come
back alive.
The goal is never the
summit of the mountain
or reaching the North
Pole or the South Pole.
Number one goal,
come back alive.
Number two, come back with
all your fingers and toes.
Number three, come
back as friends
with the people on your team.
What you have to remember
is that the summit, not only
is it not the goal, the summit
is only the halfway point.
So what you have to
think about is not just
do I have enough in me, enough
mental and physical energy
to get myself to the summit,
you have to be thinking,
do I have enough mental
and physical energy
to get myself to the summit
and get myself back down?
So most of the deaths
that occur on the mountain
occur shortly after people
have reached the summit,
because they use everything
they've got left in them to get
themselves to the top and they
don't have enough left in them
to get themselves back down.
So you have to know yourself
really well and think about
not only do I have enough
left to get me there,
but do I have enough left
to get me back down safely?
So just always keeping
in mind, the summit
is the halfway
point only, right?
You got to be able to
get yourself back down.
ERICA FOX: And once
you're back down,
did you have any sort of
routine or ritual that was--
I mean, maybe postmortem
on the formal side of it,
but even just personal,
like, a period
of reflection or depression?
Or what happens afterwards?
I mean, you've had
this amazing goal.
You've gone through
all these ordeals.
And then it's done.
What--
ALISON LEVINE: It is done.
ERICA FOX: --happens after that?
ALISON LEVINE: So
that's why I really
try never to emphasize
the summit of a mountain.
Because if you just
emphasize summits,
you're just going
to get there or not.
And then it's over.
And you think all that blood,
sweat, and tears for what,
right?
So it does go back to, for me,
post-expedition, I think about,
what did I learn along the
way that's going to help
me be better going forward?
But the other
thing I think about
is I think about the people
that paved the way before me
and who was it that had
the guts and the courage
to get out here and
do this before I ever
came to this mountain.
And I'm actually making
a documentary right now
about the first Nepali woman
to ever climb Mount Everest.
Her name was Pasang
Lhamu Sherpa.
And when she first climbed--
because I think about her all
the time on all these climbs.
She was really an
inspiration to me.
But she grew up in Nepal.
Dirt poor.
Couldn't read.
Couldn't write.
No education.
And she had this dream
to climb Mount Everest.
But she wasn't allowed to,
because she was a Sherpa woman.
And they didn't let Sherpa
women climb Mount Everest.
Sherpanis.
That's what they call them.
They weren't allowed to climb.
Only the men could climb.
And she basically said,
that's kind of like bullshit.
Women should be able to
climb this mountain too.
So the Nepali government let
women from 22 other countries
come and climb Everest, but
wouldn't let the local women
climb.
So she had the courage to
fight the government of Nepal
to allow women access to
Everest and allow women
the right to climb.
And she tried three
times unsuccessfully
to make it to the summit.
One time she got as far as
the high camp at 26,000 feet
and was told she wasn't
allowed to go to the summit,
because they didn't want
a Sherpa woman touching
the summit.
That would just ruin the
whole mountain forever, right?
So she wasn't
permitted to go on.
And that was a crusher for her.
She finally made it to the
summit on her fourth attempt
in 1993.
But she died on the descent.
She left three young
children behind.
And I think that she
was just so determined
to make it to the summit to
represent the women of Nepal.
And it was in the
early '90s and there
was the people's
movement of Nepal
and this strong
sense of nationalism
and it just became
this goal that became
much bigger than herself.
And she was so
determined to get there.
And she didn't
make it back down.
And after every climb, I
think about people like Pasang
and other people like her
that were brave enough
to go out there and do it
first and to fight the system.
Because for her, it wasn't
just about climbing a mountain,
you know, it was about women's
rights and changing things
in that country.
And it was about equality.
And it was also about
just showing people
that no matter who you
are or where you came from
or your level of education
or your demographic, whatever
your background is, if you
have a dream, then frickin'
go out there and go for it.
And so I'm so inspired by
people like her that did this.
So that's why I'm working on
this documentary now. now.
It's called "The Glass Ceiling."
So we have a little
highlight reel online.
If you want to check it out,
it's theglassceilingmovie.com.
You can learn more about Pasang.
But I just feel like when
I'm done with a climb,
I stop and I think about the
people that had the courage
to go before me because
I feel like I owe them
a lot of gratitude and
a lot of appreciation.
So that's what I think
about on these trips,
typically, are the
people that did it first,
the people that really
had the courage to get out
there long before I did.
ERICA FOX: When are you
anticipating that'll come out?
ALISON LEVINE: I don't know.
We We're going to be
doing a crowdfunding
campaign in a couple of months.
So probably if you're
connected to me in some way,
you'll get a little
email about that.
ERICA FOX:
Theglassceilingmovie.com
ALISON LEVINE:
Theglassceilingmovie.com.
Yeah, so we're going to do an
Indiegogo campaign, because we
need to raise the funds for
all the post-production costs
and everything.
So hopefully, we'll
have it finished
by the end of the year.
That's what I'm hoping.
ERICA FOX: So what's
different for you now?
Or how are you different?
If you kind of reflect
back to those days when
you were starting out and
using your frequent flyer
miles to go to Mount Kilimanjaro
and kind of bootstrapping
a lot of these expeditions,
what's different about you now?
ALISON LEVINE: What's really
different is, I think,
my level of failure tolerance.
Because I used to
think that in order
to get a sponsor
for an expedition
or to get whatever media
coverage that your team needs
to get sponsored for
the next expedition,
you have to be the best,
fastest, strongest climber,
and you have to get to
the top of the mountain.
And I really learned a
sense of failure tolerance.
And I think, in general,
we're not really
a very failure tolerant society,
which is really too bad.
Because a lack of
failure tolerance
is what stifles
progress and innovation
and prevents people from
taking risks, right?
So you've got to give
yourselves and your teams
a freedom to fail.
When you're going to
try really hard stuff
that's a huge stretch that
feels like it's completely
out of your comfort
zone, give yourselves
that freedom to fail.
Just come back from it
better the next time around.
And sometimes you look
at these people that
seem like they're these
really high achievers, that
seem perfect and they
achieve everything
they set out to achieve.
But just remember that a lot of
the times, people only achieve
something, because somebody
else got out there first
and paved the way.
And sometimes it's
the people that
get out there first that have
stumbled and fallen and been
bruised and bloodied
along the way, right?
And so give yourselves
that freedom to fail.
The other thing that
I learned is that--
and this is a super important
lesson for me to remember
and I think, for
everyone to remember--
you do not have to be the best,
fastest, strongest climber
to get to the top of a mountain.
You just have to be absolutely
relentless about putting
one foot in front of the other.
That's really all it was.
Because in 2002 when
I didn't make it
to the summit in a storm,
I think about that.
And in 2010 in a
similar situation,
we had bad weather again
in 2010 when I went back
eight years later, but I was
able to push through the storm.
And that's because I
knew a heck of a lot more
about my pain threshold,
about my risk tolerance.
I knew what it felt like to
get the living snot kicked out
of me high up on that
summit ridge in a storm
and I wasn't afraid of that
the second time around.
And so I think I've learned
to learn from my failures.
And I've learned
also that it's just
about putting one foot
in front of the other.
You don't have to be the
best, fastest, strongest.
Just be relentless.
ERICA FOX: That sounds
terrifying and exhilarating
at the same time.
OK, I'm just going to see
if anyone has questions.
ALISON LEVINE:
Ah, good question.
ERICA FOX: So let
me just repeat it
for the folks on the livestream.
A question about training
schedule and routine
throughout the year.
ALISON LEVINE: Yeah.
So I wrote a little bit
about this in the book.
And it's one of the more
controversial sections
in the book because
people call me
out on this section
all the time,
because I talk about
sleep deprivation.
ERICA FOX: We know a
fair bit about that here.
ALISON LEVINE: Right?
So the only way to really train
properly for a big expedition
is to get out to the mountains.
No amount of running,
cycling, swimming
is going to prepare
you for a big climb.
That's good for your
cardiovascular health
and your overall health, so
you should continue to do that.
But if you're going
to go to a big peak,
you got to get out
to the mountains.
So for me, I would drive
up to Mount Shasta.
Probably some of you
have been there before.
But it's just south
of the Oregon border.
So it would take me about six
hours to drive to Mount Shasta.
And I would start from the
parking lot at 11 o'clock
at night or midnight.
And I would put on
a heavy pack and I
would climb from the
base of Mount Shasta
to the summit, which is
just over 14,000 feet,
and back down in one
push with a heavy pack.
I would climb through the night.
And the reason I wanted to climb
through the night with no sleep
is because I wanted to
practice sleep deprivation.
Because in addition to
conditioning myself physically
with a heavy pack and
crampons and an ice axe
and walking up a
steep slope, I wanted
to get my body used to
that sleep deprivation.
Because on these
big expeditions,
sometimes you're going
to climb for 18, 20,
maybe 24 or more hours.
And I found that people get
really stressed out about that.
Oh, my god.
Summit day's going
to be 20 hours?
How am I going to do that?
So I like to practice
sleep deprivation
so that I know how
my body performs
when I am incredibly
sleep deprived
and I'm familiar with it.
So it doesn't stress
me out when I think,
oh, yeah, 20 hours
climbing with no sleep.
24 hours.
I can do that.
I practice that all the time.
Is it good for you to go
without sleep a bunch of times?
No, it's terrible for you.
But I didn't write a book
about how to live to be 100.
I wrote a book about how to get
through the toughest of times
when you absolutely have to.
So for me, part of that is
just sleep deprivation training
on top of the physical
training for these expeditions.
ERICA FOX: Are you
climbing now still?
ALISON LEVINE: I just did
a climb this past November.
I went back to Nepal
to this remote area
called the Rolwaling Valley.
I went with two
girlfriends of mine
that live in the French Alps.
And we spent a couple
of weeks over there.
We did the first ascent of
this peak called Khang Karpo.
It's a 22,000-foot peak over
in the Rolwaling Valley.
We were the first
people to ever climb it.
So it was incredibly
challenging, but also really
rewarding and a lot of
fun to go to a mountain
that nobody had ever climbed
before because there's
no beta at all on the peak.
You kind of have to figure
things out as you go.
And we went with an amazing team
of Sherpas that were actually
from that village.
So they knew their way
around there really well.
And they were incredible.
And it was fun.
It was the second first
ascent I had done.
I did one last year, the
first ascent of Hall Peak
in Antarctica.
The seven summits or the
Adventure Grand Slam.
So it wasn't really like
I set out to do that.
Because you don't get anything
when you complete the Grand
Slam.
You don't even get a free
breakfast at Denny's.
You get nothing.
I had to buy my own
Grand Slam breakfast.
But for whatever reason, I
started climbing these peaks.
And I would go to a mountain
and I would meet people there.
And then they would invite
me on another expedition.
So then I'd end up on another
one of the seven summits
and then another one
of the seven summits.
And before I knew
it, I had climbed
six of the seven summits.
And I thought, oh,
well, I'll never
do the seven summits, because
how could I go to Everest?
I couldn't afford that.
And I don't have the
time off of work.
And I have all this
student loan debt.
And that would never be
something I could do.
Well, sure enough, where
there's a will, there's a way.
And I ended up actually
getting an invitation
to join the First American
Women's Everest Expedition
and serve as the team captain.
And we got Ford as a
sponsor, so that covered
the financial end of it.
And then this was
shortly after 9/11.
And I had this new
job at Goldman Sachs.
I was a new associate there
right out of grad school.
And I was a very junior
level person there.
But it was after 9/11 and all
the investment banking firms
were laying people off.
And so I thought, well,
maybe I could take
an unpaid leave of absence.
And the timing was
perfect after 9/11.
So I was like, could I
get two months unpaid?
And they were like, two months?
Sure thing.
Take six months.
Take the whole
department with you.
So it was just
good timing that I
was able to take the time off.
But then, of course, we
didn't make it in 2002.
So it wasn't until
eight years later
where I actually
completed the Grand Slam.
But it wasn't like I set
out to do that as a goal,
it just kind of
ended up happening,
where I didn't
even know there was
such a thing as the
Adventure Grand Slam
until I got to Everest
base camp in 2010
and was talking with some other
people about my experiences
on other mountains.
And I was talking about how much
I liked my polar expeditions as
well.
And this guy said, oh, you've
been to the North and South
Pole?
If you summit Everest,
you know, that's
the Adventure Grand Slam.
And I said, I don't even
know what that is, but great.
So that's how I
ended up doing it.
It wasn't really
anything I set out
to do as a goal ahead of time.
ERICA FOX: OK,
how, if at all, did
the danger of
climbing Mount Everest
factor into your
attempts at the mountain?
ALISON LEVINE: So you're always
aware when you're in these
remote extreme environments
where you cannot control things
around you and there are all
these elements that affect
your climb.
So the weather is probably
the most obvious thing
that people think
about, the weather,
but there are other things too.
Your health, the health of
the team, the conditions
of the route, the conditions
of your gear, all these things
can change and you
can't control any of it.
So Mount Everest really bad
place for control freaks.
So it goes back
to, first of all,
being able to take action based
on this situation at the time.
I think that helps with
some of the risk, right?
Mitigating some of that risk.
And then just always--
I realize these
situations are dangerous,
but being very
hyperaware of everything
that's going on around you.
So I always tell people that a
healthy dose of fear, I think,
is what helps you survive
in these environments.
So fear is what I
use to sort of help
me stay on top of everything
that's going on around me.
So fear's just a normal
human emotion, right?
So don't ever beat
yourself up for feeling
scared or intimidated.
Fear, I use it to my advantage.
It keeps me awake, alert, on
my toes, aware of everything
going on around me.
Fear's fine.
Complacency is what
will kill you, right?
When you're in
these environments
where there is a lot of inherent
risk and a lot of danger,
it's complacency
that is dangerous.
So stay scared, right?
Stay scared.
Stay intimidated by the
mountain and just keep
an eye out for everything
going on around you.
And don't be afraid to just
pull the plug on the whole thing
and head back down if that's
the right thing to do.
ERICA FOX: Great.
Another question
from the livestream.
How do you finance
your expeditions?
And can you talk about
how this has changed
from when you started to now?
ALISON LEVINE: So fundraising is
one of my least favorite things
in the world.
But it is a necessary evil
when it comes to these trips.
An Everest expedition
right now, just the
permit to go to Everest
is $11,000 per person.
So when we were fundraising,
the cost was about $25,000
a person.
I had $70,000 of debt.
I didn't know
anyone else who was
a climber who had any money.
So we had to go out and
raise the funds for the trip.
And I ended up connecting
with a friend of mine
from grad school who worked in
the Mercury division of Ford.
And he helped us funnel the idea
of the First American Women's
Everest Expedition up to
the senior Ford executives
in Michigan.
And they actually agreed
to fund our entire trip.
And they agreed to fund us,
because our expedition just
happened to coincide
with the launch
of their new full-size SUV,
which was, of course, the Ford
Expedition.
So it was perfect timing, right?
ERICA FOX: Serendipity.
ALISON LEVINE: Right?
There you go.
So perfect timing for that.
And it was just all about
casting a really wide net.
I sent so many
proposal letters out
to so many companies and so many
individuals trying to get help.
And I was raising money
for this cancer research
foundation called the V
Foundation at the same time.
So I was trying to raise
money for this cancer research
grant, which was completely
separate from fundraising
for the expedition.
So I was soliciting
donations and ideas
and stuff all the time.
And what sparked the
thing for Ford is,
I was at the Half Moon
Bay pumpkin festival.
And I'd been trying to
fundraise for so long.
And we just kept
getting no, no, no, no.
I'm at the Half Moon
Bay pumpkin festival.
And I walk by this-- they
call it a concept car, which
is a car that might
be on display that's
not in actual production or no
plans for actual production.
But I walk past this
humongous white SUV
and it's called the
Himalayan Expedition.
And it's this big Ford thing.
And I was like, oh, timeout!
I was like, wait a
minute, this is it.
And I'm looking at this
big, monstrous SUV.
It was like, this is it!
This is it!
Ford!
I'd been brainstorming all these
ideas more related to sports.
And I was trying Nike and
Adidas and people at ESPN.
I sent a letter to Dick Vitale.
Can you help us?
And he sent me back a 8 by
10 glossy with his signature
on it.
I was like, that's not going
to get me to the mountain,
but thank you, because
I was a Dickie V fan.
But it was just that idea,
like, the Half Moon Bay pumpkin
festival is what
sparked that idea.
Seeing that concept car on
display, I thought, Ford.
Wait a minute.
And then I thought, oh, I know
a guy that works in the Mercury
division of Ford.
I don't know him well, but
he was in my business school
class.
So I reached out to him.
He funneled the idea up
through the people at Ford.
Their director of global
marketing was a woman.
She liked the idea.
So that's just how you do it.
And then I've also had
people actually approach me
for other expeditions,
where they
say, we're sponsoring
this expedition,
will you be a part of it?
And so I think having all the
media coverage of our 2002
expedition, even though
we didn't make it,
sort of helped me get on the
radar of some other expeditions
that were planning things and
got roped into them that way.
ERICA FOX: So we have a lot of
Googlers in the room-- sorry,
guys, I'm just asking
one more question--
in the room and
on the livestream
who are amazing at
what they do and work
with people and data
and places and maps
and all of the products
that Google has.
If you could direct
our energies,
do you have any suggestions
or requests of us,
given that you've been
to such amazing places
in the world that are touched
by the things that we do
and also the efforts
that we stand behind?
ALISON LEVINE: So
this is something
that I've learned
in every workplace,
every polar environment, and
every mountain I've been to,
something that
makes a difference.
So sometimes we're so focused
on innovation and performance
and doing our jobs and achieving
more and this and that,
and you set these
really high goals
and you want to achieve them.
But what we sometimes
forget about
is to focus on the
people around us
and reminding those people
how valuable they are to you,
how valuable they
are to the team,
and how important
they are to you.
For example, on my 2010
Everest expedition,
there was a guy on the trip
who was the strongest climber
physically on the team.
He was 6'4, former Navy guy.
He had a PhD from MIT.
This guy was so smart,
so strong physically,
so much experience, strongest
guy on the trip every day.
For whatever reason, when it
came time for our summit push,
he started struggling.
And we got to Camp
2 and he said,
I don't know if I'm
going to continue.
He said, I can't feel my hands.
I can't feel my feet.
I feel this tingling sensation.
I'm feeling some
anxiety about going on.
And I may turn back.
And I thought, this guy has
been such an amazing teammate.
He is such a strong climber.
He was out in front every day.
I don't want him to turn back.
And so I said to him
at dinner, I said,
you are not going to turn back.
I said, you are such an
important part of this team.
And if you're not standing
on the summit with me,
that summit is not going to
mean nearly as much to me.
What can I do?
What can the rest
of us do to help
you to get you to keep going?
Because I'm telling
you, I don't really
want to go unless
you're there too.
And he thought about
it for a few minutes.
And he said, you know what?
I'll give it a try.
And he made it to the summit.
But a couple of weeks
after we got back,
he sent me this really
nice note in the mail.
And he said, thank you so
much for the encouragement
at Camp 2, because that is
what got me off the fence
and convinced me to continue.
And I thought, well, it was
just a few words just saying,
I don't want you to turn back.
You're important to me.
I want you to be there.
I want to high-five you or
fist bump you at the summit.
It's not going to
mean as much to me--
this journey isn't going
to mean as much to me
if you're not on it too.
And it really taught me the
importance of telling people
how important they are because
you never know the impact
that a few kind words can have.
And you assume that
people know because they
got a promotion or they got
a raise or they got a bonus
or whatever, you assume
they know how valuable they
are to you and to the team and
how important they are to you.
But everybody needs that
boost every now and then.
Even the strongest performers
have their down days.
Even the most skilled people
have periods of doubt.
And if you can be that
person to just give somebody
a little encouragement and tell
them how much they mean to you
and how important
they are to the team,
that can really
make a difference
in outcomes in
certain situations.
So I would say, in
addition to focusing
on technology and
innovation and market share
and all that stuff, focus
on the people around you
and reminding them how
important they are.
ERICA FOX: Thank you.
And I really appreciate
you coming and sharing
your adventures--
ALISON LEVINE: Yeah, thanks
for having me, you guys.
Thanks for allowing
me to be your guest.
ERICA FOX: --tips and
recommendations for all of us.
It's incredibly inspiring.
ALISON LEVINE: Yeah,
thanks, you guys.
ERICA FOX: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]